imagine política de que hoje a 18 de
dezembro
o paulo é seu aniversário de 90 anos
precisamos exigir a cabeça e não só em
situações assim o tempo compartilhar com
vocês eu vou que liberou 10 93 anos de
idade
meu avô dele pé direito e apenas útil de
começou no chão de fábrica começou a
trabalhar no chão de fábrica naquela
tarde ele conquistou que muitos diria
que é uma história de sucesso e até 90 e
poucos anos como se deve à falta de hoje
ele e é um jornal diariamente ia para
sua empresa para se interar de tudo está
acontecendo no mundo e também da empresa
eu me lembro belo dia quando ele chegou
em casa seus 88 anos por aí como a
cardiológica
nossa ele tinha a falar desse canal da
tecnologia que tinha surgido e tinha
decidido naquele momento que era hora de
começar um novo negócio
as 88 obviamente com a idade avançada
a junta de 88 foi encontrar outro
parceiro o seu bem mais jovem
você tem poucos anos e começar a empresa
que existe até hoje
sonhar de querer transformar sonhos em
realidade é da natureza do ser humano
eu vou nacionais jorge o seu futuro e
deixar de alguma forma um legado de meu
sonho eu sonho com quem teve o ps teve
esse é meu sonho de consumo
só que ao longo da vida foi amadurecendo
a idéia e fui percebendo que o pacto
flávio botes infláveis de ar plástico a
mesma combinação muito bem com os aviões
jatos na base em matéria de ferro
titanic saída das poucas opções e foi se
transformando
até que me conter e na educação
ambiental e lá conheci
jorge dada nas escolas de periferia de
boston é o lado dos estados unidos e é
uma região que era marcado pela
violência pelas drogas pelo crime e pela
pobreza também é colocar altas muitas
escolas e muitas turmas já era princípio
mais uma criança
até que um dia joão toda criança
só que quando eu deixei pra olhar olho
no olho com essa criança de seis anos
o susto no rosto estampado no rosto as
marcas nas rugas profundas da dor e do
sofrimento
já o doutor
nesse momento eu falei com os que eu vou
fazer neste momento é porque mesmo com
muita chapa ela crescer anos com a
palavra mágica gosta do tom sofreu mas
não era um olhar dedicação que ele tinha
um olhar forte de gay e que dizia eu não
sou vizinho currículo na cabeça
já comprei a salvar um falava que eu
faço hoje que o beijo mais é isso que
falam
no minuto que a gente entra aumento que
mesmo entre a escola colocou o capacete
e fala pra ele olha para frente norte os
lados e olha corra corra corra teve seu
melhor chegada da corrida foi o primeiro
são os primeiros dos perdedores da
campanha ocorrida ativamente
então a nossa vida real tem todos tenham
acesso ao que a gente tá bom momento não
é bom mas também nunca deixavam a 3º
andar vila jorge é que agora dá é é
raridade
beto carreiro a cana para se ver essa
coisa mas nos bastidores do mundo o que
a gente tem ultra turbina disse long
jack
mas a gente é fazer a gente tem fé é
aqui onde a gente falasse filho vai
quebrar vai lá e correr quando ficarmos
falando que você vai ganhar assim vai
validar e antes de começar a corrida
teve a educação hoje ela só faltará
gente
quanto maior melhor performance hoje
educação e faz procurada para isso a
prefeitura a desigualdade social é
impensável e assegurar poxa não mas que
deve ser só em países é ser bem pau não
pensa que é o gráfico de um país de
primeiro mundo e da mesma forma que isso
acontece neste país acontece tanto com a
resistência do vento faz cercos países
pobres
essa realidade que terá de hoje todos os
sistemas educacionais
é uma parte nova da escola sem volta
okay assim como também do lado direito
aqui momento o carro certo lá todo mundo
aqui no meio dos nossos vídeos
vamos deixar ele mas não havia defeito
nos jogos
não estou falando de john
um pra bater tanto de carro
qualquer forma se descolar da escola
acho qual a chance 30 numa boa
universidade
acho que há uma chance de ele teve uma
boa jornada na carreira profissional
como se a universidade não está boa acho
que escolhas então razão do jogo
quando a gente fecha o olho é para essa
disparidade social e aceita esse status
quo
aos poucos a gente vai perder os
respectivos jogos
foi uma vida de refinação e desesperança
eu acho que vocês podem ver eu não acho
que esse foi o edital que estudou muito
estudo e conseguiu a mortalidade na vila
e de fato isso acontece
esses são os heróis solitários porque a
maior parte dessas crianças se encontrar
no lado esquerdo do gráfico continuam no
ciclo vicioso da pobreza e da violência
e essa pessoa que vai comandar muito meu
pai não vai além dele da lista é
enquanto jovem sonhava democracia e
sonhávamos com o mundo de 2010 iniciar
as mesmas porque no fundo quando ele
acreditava que todo ser humano tem
potencial para fazer coisas incríveis
mas a realidade com que se depararam na
vida real não atua no mercado de
trabalho as pessoas muito mais
preocupadas em combater cartão e
obedecer o que pensava e sons e naquela
época ele já dizia em algo muito mais em
educação
a gente tá perdendo não as pessoas que
pensam que está querendo robôs e como
não poderia ser diferente ele também
ganhou um sonho apesar de seu empresário
da indusval ele sonhou com uma educação
de qualidade fatores que se dizia muito
orgulho estar aqui na marquês de sapucaí
que está na dura ele levar ele amava o
brasil e dirigiu país e orgulhoso falava
eu sou brasileiro é e tinha essa questão
de trazer empresários tudo no mundo
inteiro desde o ano inteiro pra mim
conhecer o país que ele tanto amava
idiota educação taxa de inflação
ele amava tanto o brasil teve pequenas a
gente até esquece o quão maravilhoso é
esse país não mudarão as pessoas de
todas
todas as raças todas as culturas têm o
privilégio chamar esse lugar de lá de
casa
e ao final da audiência o que a gente
quer da vida não é o lugar onde a gente
pode sentir de poder rodeada de amigos a
gente faz sentir bem realizar sequência
de alguma forma mas de repente a gente
tem um filho atualmente a corrida de
balão
a gente não pára por aí a gente fica
preocupado não só com nossa filha vai
bem não vai bem na vida a gente fica
preocupada com o filho do vizinho também
quer é que ele vai ser melhor o meu
filho e de repente descobre que o filho
do vizinho
só peguei meus nove anos de idade
e aí tinha bala puxa não aguentava nem
não
já casado que nada da vida tão defasado
na vida que só pessoa assim reconhece
albertin ele filho do vizinho lembra que
tem 29 anos de idade e assim como a
personagem de novela vargens ao longo da
história da unidade na argentina em
algum momento com escola deles foram
considerados inaptos para a tv pra
aprender capazes de certas coisas foram
condenados em algum momento pela
sociedade dizer que a base e por alguma
razão ele trabalhar porque é de muita
dedicação e muito esforço e muita
disciplina e de repente se tornar
parece que fazem a gente quer puxar a
criança tem que fazer a gente está
procurando elly geniozinho pequenos de
rodas menino de dois anos três anos a
fazer vai fazer tal coisa e tal mas não
aqui no espaço dos gênios escolas duas
disciplinas de treino e de previdência e
eu aceitei hoje mostra é isso que na
verdade depois não é de simplesmente
está a despertar existe uma realidade
diferente todos e se ele vai ficar ou
não depende do ponto exposto cada um de
nós está disposto a trabalhar fiz o
aparelho quando a gente botou o github
data em 1998
nós partimos à imprensa pelo menos
liberdade inerente a todo ser humano é
depositada de alguma forma fazer esse
potencial favorável mas não somente a
formar pessoal próprio umbigo
porque as pessoas que falarão fazer
mesmas temos muitos nomes que a gente
precisa de pessoas que estão
comprometidas começar maior ea gente fez
uma educação pautada com as pesquisas
o primeiro teoria substituem referência
de limpa educação feminina
vou perguntar pra cada um de vocês aqui
o que marcou a sua experiência
internacional
quantos de vocês vão falar e foi para a
sala de aula de centenas de aula
ou será que fazer vou falar não faz feio
que eu fiz o tc pela primeira vez até 29
de repente a eureka deu certo aí eu pedi
a carteira
geralmente é isso que marca as pessoas
com aquele momento que você brincou fez
o que fez e formulou é o conceito que de
alguma forma aquilo fez sentido para
fazer o pedido pra gente é compartilhar
tudo não é uma idéia a gente precisa
chegar a le a gente precisa também ter
essa disposição para dar nosso melhor
para a sociedade então ser uma não se de
repente se torna é tão normal nós em
quantidade nunca ter feito nada
a gente precisa no momento dessa criança
toma consciência de si é importante
começar a fazer exercício da cidadania
que eles conseguem de verdade chegar ao
fórum do contribuinte para o bem estar
maior à medida que eles vão fazer esses
ensaios para a vida
pouco a pouco ele escutou
entendo como as coisas estão todos
interligados que não faz aqui a falta
outro lado que somos apenas uma pequena
gota uma edição 12 ano e esse oceano
inserido dentro da mãe natureza e aos
poucos eles vão perceber que somos
escola no turno e eles vão adquirindo
essa sabedoria porque é reconhecer a
unidade que existe essa diversidade é
uma terapia que acontece quando você
educa falta desses princípios onde esses
princípios permeiam fazer todos os
educadores
recentemente a gente abriu espaço para
pôr o be sobe é compartilhar seus olhos
ou têm a oportunidade de gerenciar seus
sonhos compartilhar com vocês o convênio
o que vem à cabeça quando vocês pensam
na escola
recentemente uma jovem de 17 anos que
chegou isso como uma oportunidade de
transformação mandar nela seguinte
possamos estudar eles não têm a chance
de estudar a cana nessa tela e tenho
força tem uma escola que ela quis também
é o mesmo prazer de aprender como eu
escrevi então que ela fez foi conversar
com minhas rodas ou passar e quando ela
usou na final da copa da itália tinha um
é ou não de vida dela eu vou apostar eu
vou comprometer que ajuda a organizar
realizadas só dele e ela não tô questões
é uma sequência difícil de uma estrutura
de jovens em imagem do jovem para voltar
ao final das inscrições
em gaia estão a comentar e romina da
criação de um centro de educação em nado
e criado pelos próprios jovens
uma jovem de 17 anos tentando realizando
o sonho de outro jovem e este aqui
outro projeto que realmente uma
assistência na crise está nessa cena
preferência de um grupo de três meninos
de 11 anos
a crise gerou certo desconforto
a bossa nova no mundo precisam fazer ao
papa com o fato de não poder brincar no
quintal não pareça mais importante é que
a gente vai fazer pra preservar a água é
porque o mundo está sofrendo com isso
para ela isso descobriram que essa linha
tem um componente ele terá que é ótimo a
gente vai ter que ter isso não sabia
antibactericida conta corta com um monte
de coisas para eles não faz assim é uma
coisa que todo mundo tenta saber que
para ele porque eu ia fazer 1 a 1
o projeto em cima da salsinha e da água
que foi desenvolver uma tecnologia de
reaproveitamento de água pra muita
atenção de votos necessitava de um
projeto de obra sustentável
agora estão mexendo por sensores e
circuitos para fazer esse sistema auto
contínuo a mais bacana essa experiência
toda ficou com esse sistema
peles e aí você achava experiência a
primeira coisa que me faz muito feliz
porque a gente achou a gente passou por
algumas dificuldades o projeto dele na
vila desmontou em algum momento na
véspera ter que pegar o projeto e eles
tiveram fé ea gente acredita na fala de
si mesmo
a gente acreditou que a gente está
sentindo muito realizada porque o
projeto não é pra gente pra todos e essa
fase vai percebendo como as crianças
jovens e jovens têm capacidade de
enxergar além de seu vínculo
esta é uma acção que a gente tinha lá
fazer à medida que a gente vai abrir a
porta para desenvolver infecções jovens
algo muito interessante acontece até a
fé é o sonho e médio
esse projeto se materializando o projeto
de crianças de 5º ao 3º ano do médio que
vão aparecendo na medida que você vai
aprender estar mais espaço pra ele o que
a gente tinha em mente fazer aqui é a
educação a serviço da diversidade humana
e não dá total dedicação da mente humana
a gente acredita que é uma área que
quero é que é muito importante de
dólares até porque a gente está fazendo
o seguinte quero resgatar o verdadeiro
sentido da palavra no carro para sair
para fora conduzir viatura fazendo o que
está fora fazer essa genialidade do ser
humano
o bem estar social maior mas o que a
gente mais precisa neste momento é isso
que eu tenho pressa pra gente
já vai
bom eu não tinha coragem de subir lá mas
agora eu encorajei explico que a gente
mais precisa é de coragem coragem de
todos os setores da sociedade porque
como diz o ditado africano é que eles
voltem inteira educar uma criança é
preciso que os professores das visitas
dos pais ela é precisa uma sociedade que
tenha daqui vestibular não é o fim mas é
um meio de uma criança
assim a gente vai conseguir pouco a
pouco transformar essa a educação que
hoje existe está falando de resgate do
carro
o foco tem que ser como ela extrai do
texto natureza
o seu melhor a gente precisa é dar um
basta em tanta correria de hoje
correria da educação digital basta
tentar essa tentativa de turbinar jéci e
devolver o cão quem realmente dela é
transformar esses sonhos dos jovens no
rebote
eu gostaria apenas de finalizar com algo
que você decidir
e para a gente pegar mas entende melhor
identificar os bandidos
tudo isso é muito bom